joining us now is retired advice
Marshall Sean Bell good to see you again
thanks Sean thanks for coming in just
what is Russia trying to achieve with
this these renewed attacks real barrage
hasn't there been in in recent hours and
days yeah yesterday was the ninth of
these large-scale Russian missile
attacks across the whole of Ukraine
targeting the Ukrainian energy
infrastructure we've been covering it
for some time although it was across the
whole country excuse me the main attacks
seem to be at Kiev at the North and
around Hearthstone down to the South
here
um the Ukrainian air defense systems are
improving they claim that they've shot
down 37 of the 14 missile attacks that
were due Target here they seem to be
Russia firing them from the sea of azer
of the Black Sea but also krasna da down
here is where the Drone soon to launch
from they were being launched from
Crimea looks likely that to try and stop
the ukrainians attacking as you say
these are um just seem to be designed to
erode the civilian support for the war
but most specifically they don't appear
to be helping Putin's military
objectives one jot what else is going on
like their specifics aren't they but
what else is happening around the
country yeah so across the country
fighting continues but uh it seems
evident now that Putin has ordered the
taking of Donetsk and therefore the
fighting is most uh focused around here
particularly around the town of bathmuth
um Russians are still trying to encircle
it
um they are taking huge casualties they
still have failed but they are making
really incremental gains if we look to
the north the ukrainians are trying to
cut this Russian line of communication
here trying to stop the resupply of of
equipment and supplies down down to Bath
moot interesting to note that the
Russians are also digging a lot of
trench systems miles and miles and miles
of trenches now many of the viewers will
know that from World War One World War
II trenches were the Great protection
against artillery and the shrapnel which
is one of the biggest killers on the
battlefield the trouble is in the 21st
century particularly in the winter with
drones being used by both sides trench
systems are really obvious the drones
and likewise for very accurate Precision
weapons that provided by the West will
make the Russian forces in those
trenches very vulnerable yeah
interesting
um how credible is a potential attack on
on Cube yeah I mean it was an
interesting piece wasn't it listening to
the military commanders part of the
military role is to constantly review
military options and to look at what's
the worst case scenario and work out
what mitigations you'd have kiev is
undoubtedly the center of gravity for
Ukraine in other words it's the source
of power for zelenski and therefore will
be a target for Russia regardless but
there's lots of factors as to whether
Russia could actually take care one of
them is geographic Russia is quite
somewhere away from Kiev if you're going
to amount this you'd mount it out of
Belarus at the top there it's pretty
clear lukashenko is a natural political
Ally of Putin but the Belarusian people
and the military have made very clear
they do not want to get involved in this
war at all interestingly Putin
lukashenko due to meet in two days time
no doubt pressure will impede increase
on the kashenko in terms of other
equipment though um Belarus has been
providing tanks and other military
equipment to Russia what Russia will
also need those people we've been
covering this but 300 000 mobilized 150
000 have already been put into the fight
150 000 the other remaining 150 000
their training should be complete early
in the new year and therefore they could
be used but we'd get early indications
if you remember back in February we saw
early indications the Russian buildup of
forces we've seen none of that as yet if
you remember Russia failed the first
time it tried to take care of it will
have learned the lessons but so will
Ukraine and it'd be very difficult for
that campaign uh to actually uh succeed
I think on reflection it's it's helpful
for Russia to use the media to raise the
prospect of potential strike as a
deception operation to make Ukraine on
back foot but likewise for Ukraine it's
worth them keeping this highlighted as a
grave threat to them to keep it in the
profile of the West because they need
the West's help despite the other
domestic distractions yeah all right
Sean thank you for now